I am NOT comparing david hog to Hitler
use at all no comparison other than the
hand and the armband that's the only
thing it's but it's incidental in the
gun control that's the likely socialism
in the overall demure stature with
distinctive jawline and general
malfeasance but no more comparison to
the hail at night here's my questioning
for everyone out there today do you
think the kids like David Hogg should be
off-limits when is it okay to criticize
them and to what degree what do you
think genuinely I would like to know
okay let me start this by saying I
cannot even begin to imagine so I
wouldn't even pretend to the trauma of a
massacre like what occurred at the
school and very empathetic to anyone
involved okay I think everybody is too
let's just let's get that off of the
table because okay my grandfather died
when I was in the sixth grade closest
relative of mine that was really really
hard period later I was a dick when I
poured grape juice into my friends
lunchbox two separate issues okay
entirely separate victim and then I was
the bully I think David hog is a bully
this is just my opinion here's why
everyone has a right to an opinion okay
everyone has the right to voice an
opinion of course you do mr. Hogg but
when you enter the public arena to voice
it or specifically proposed legislation
everyone has the right to criticize that
opinion that's that's my opinion any
issue so when is it okay if ever to get
personal oh typically the rule is if the
other person draws first blood if they
get personal and then we murky it all up
with the whole age factor and that's
what really bothers me about the
situation this is what bothers when we
see just just the degrading of our
national dialogue to the identity pop to
this degree
David hog I think he's wrong I think
he's unprofessional I think on a
personal level he's on his way to being
if he isn't already a bad human being
here's why they're pathetic [ __ ] that
want to keep killing our children they
could have blood from children
splattered all over their faces and they
wouldn't take action because they all
still see those dollar signs he does not
give a about these kids lives at all he
only cares about his reelection okay
yeah now that would seem kind of kind of
you know yeah sure Kish uh but the thing
is when you say hey you know what you
really probably shouldn't talk about
people that way he goes into the
on the age thing when people try to
suppress your vote and there are people
who stand against you because you're too
young we say no mom at this point it's
like when you're when you're old as
parents like I don't know how to send an
iMessage you know just like give me the
phone and you take him you're like okay
let me handle it and you get it done in
one second sadly that's what we have to
do with our government because our
parents don't know how to use up
democracy so we have to and they'll be
mildly off-putting in and of itself if
you didn't add on top of it the rampant
hypocrisy but what she does most the
time is she's like oh these leftist
leftist group is trying to take all you
she gets this really threatening tone
about us that we don't have we love
everyone like we're people that just
want to come want everybody to come
together as Americans and help us solve
this issue a mean tone that's the
pissant pot calling the kettle [ __ ] by
the way to those who's good let's go
after her sponsors go for it give it
your best shot
what are gonna do dee bonnet eyes this
extra he's just a 17 year old
Christopher Titus
I'm unhinged because you know my 32,000
Americans you build and and that you're
not that you're not unhedged about that
is kind of upsetting of course of course
you're upset mr. Titus no picture if I
were to come back with a logical
argument een I'm 17 it's always this is
what really bothers me is there is the
left is using obviously this horrible
tragedy to create a cybernetic victim
super human who you cannot touch doesn't
matter what he says doesn't matter how
much he insults people doesn't matter
how much he goes out and he takes
potshots doesn't matter how personal he
gets if anyone responds even critically
they want to say how could you do that
would somebody please think of the
children he's six months from being able
to vote yeah okay anyone here's the deal
even at 17 18 there we don't let
emotional people determine our laws okay
which is what they're trying to do right
now we don't say well oh you can't do
you can't do this unless you've been in
imagining we don't allow exclusively
rape victims to determine rape laws no
no at all matter of fact police
suffering trauma doesn't make you more
of a qualified as expert in anything at
all usually police circle back and ask
you to calm down because your memories
fuzzy things get cleared the
further you get away from the trauma and
here's the teenagers it's they have a
lack of critical rational thinking
ability they do not have a fully
developed brain this kid for example
he's not there's no self-awareness he's
not aware the fact that teenage drivers
aged 6 to 16 to 19 I think 3 times 3 or
4 times more likely than drivers aged 20
to be in a fatal crash ok and that's
that's why they can't get car insurance
on a rental car without paying an
exorbitant fee until you're 25 he's not
self-aware to understand the record
number of teenagers consuming Tide Pods
yeah he also lacks the self-awareness to
know that doing this whole salute well
wearing the armband kind of rubs people
the wrong way
oops
I want to make this really clear I'm not
saying ok hashtag all kids or even that
no hashtag kids opinions don't matter
that's that's not at all what I'm saying
I'm not saying because he's young that
his in his opinion is invalid but some
kids do want believable things and he's
not even Asian how is he so talented
damn you damn you and your cornea cope
you have skills mr. Shapiro the problem
I have here and I don't know what how
you is is the unfair weaponization of
teenagers entering the public arena
espousing opinions demanding policy
changes and then claiming underaged
immunity from any and all criticism yeah
are you the child I need expert I think
the handlers propping him up doing that
saying ok maybe people are gonna touch
this guy we'll just put him out there
and let him get it seems to me that
you're the expert they have a hog the
exploitation of youth by the way for
political gain is not a new thing yes
cake context Hitler Youth was the thing
now just to be clear it's an example of
politicization of children I am NOT
comparing David hog to Hitler Youth at
all no comparison other than the hand in
the armband that's the only thing it's
but it's incidental in the gun control
that's the likely socialism in the
overall demure stature with distinct
left with jawline and general
malfeasance but no more comparison to
the hill at 9 9 more comparisons
sponsors go for its people like handy to
give him the spotlight because he'd like
what he says but when you look at this
he acts like he wants to really push for
legislation well was it was he doing to
do so no he's
get on CNN and Oprah and Ellen and
talking all about ideas but he he brags
about hanging up on the White House
right examine Trump he goes on and on
all buzz hates you for Marco Rubio and
it's like but why doesn't he care about
dead children the four years that none
of the overwhelming dislike ratio that
you see online including on channels
like CNN is because David hog let me
speak directly to you because I know
you're watching I'm gonna try and go
after the sponsors please go nuts it's
not because you're seventeen it's not
because you're a liberal none of it is
due to a lack of empathy for what you've
gone through okay we all want solutions
we just have different ideas can we do
this is one thing hopefully you'll learn
David hog that everyone actually cares
most people actually care they just
happen to have different ideas and you
need to allow room for that to be the
case you can't talk about bringing
people together and then say no one can
come together if it does if we don't all
agree entirely and then I'm gonna hang
up on the president here's the Prada man
the platform to speak refused to engage
or debate with anyone from any other
point of view claimed to be a child when
it's convenient then switch hats and
claim that people better take your ideas
seriously while chastising swearing at
people name-calling simultaneously
demanding that everyone else be civil it
has nothing to do with your age and
everything to do with the fact that
you're manipulative divisive verbally
abusive bully who wants a different set
of standards applied to you and your
friends for the kind of behavior which
would have had you kindly removed from
the restaurant in any other scenario
here's the deal I want you to do well
David hog I want you to grow up and be
successful I hope that you change the
world great go nuts but for that to
happen
someone's got to discipline you a little
bit the real world has red pens the real
world has wooden spoons the real world
has consequences when you enter an arena
and you choose a weapon as you have done
with the social political arena and the
policies that you're proposing which by
the way strip other people there for a
middle human rights you better be ready
for what the real world has to offer
maybe you can twitter bully a few cable
news hosts maybe you can twitter bully a
few classmates hell maybe you can bully
YouTube into getting this video removed
or at least e monetized as hate speech
for all I care
but you'll soon find out that in the
real world mr. Hogg you can't Twitter
bully all your potential bosses you
can't bully all your potential wives or
husbands you can't bully all of your
classmates and your work colleagues into
agreeing with you David Hogg I'm trying
to help you let me be clear I'm trying
to help you because pretty soon and I
mean within a matter of weeks a matter
of months at most all of these media
stars all the starlets who've been using
and they've been using they've been
exploiting you they're not going to be
there they're not going to be calling
hell they probably won't even be
answering your own calls if some kid
that happens to bring an alarm clock in
a suitcase to school or fly in a bubble
you'll be last week's news and you'll be
finding yourself looking around
wondering where all of your cool new
friends are they won't be there finding
your voice is great but don't allow
yourself to be exploited don't allow
yourself to be used by people who don't
care about you because they're not going
to be here really soon and then you're
gonna be left with the real world and
you're gonna find out that the real
world doesn't always agree with you and
you can't just cuss them out and tell
them if they don't know how to use their
iPhones properly so I want you to learn
this lesson now because when that
happens who are you gonna think it's not
gonna be Anderson Cooper's not gonna be
dead johnny mathis but your old uncle
Stephen did you enjoy this video here's
your thing you wrote you're here this is
the end of it so we don't care cuz you
already watched it but if you really
didn't like it
and you want to justify it leave a
comment below telling us why you didn't
like the video and if you liked us let
us know and subscribe to the channel
because that lets the overlords at
YouTube know that you know what you're
alright